[Musique]
c'est lors d'une compilation de jeux
allaient la machine est lancée c'est
parti pour le premier jeu ouais
franchement art et tous les accessoires
et tous les jours je suis là avec ça je
souffre et hop tu fais là me [ __ ]
j'aurais jamais dû acheter tout ça ça va
signer mon bureau jusqu'à la fin de ma
vie alors on commence avec un jeu qui
s'appelle ait porn cacher le porno ne me
jugez pas voilà ça juste direct c'est un
problème auquel chaque homme a fait face
ben ouais c'est plus je pense nos
parents qui ont fait face à ce problème
tu sais où il acheté des magazines lie
définit aujourd'hui les jeunes vont sur
des sites pornographiques je parle comme
s'il était vieux mais à l'époque il
fallait vraiment trouver toute trace de
deux magazines elle est cachée avec tam
est arrivé dans ta chambre tu dois te
mettais une vilaine fait c'est des
tissus utilisés mais qui met sa part
terme en maintenant c'est sérieux mais
ça c'est un truc pour se laver les mains
c'est moyen mais y'a rien mais la meuf
elle a vu quoi je peux y compris
l'algérie et le mali j'ai retiré les
tissus à l'historique à ça ça c'est un
problème d'aujourd'hui ça non n'y a rien
là c'est ma mère a une gueule de sucé
jusqu'à la bête méchante c'est bon mais
là comme en gueulant quoi qu'il arrive
je gagnais mais l'école marie margolin
très bien haut mais menant vers le mégot
direz c'est un fleuve quoiqu'en
voisinage et torturé il reste des
magazines vite fait à la base d une cure
je les ai vus c'est bon narbonne a plus
rien et la rive encore gueulant mais
maman mais tu peux venir m par
l'étranger on peut avoir une amitié mère
fils qui est bien mieux omerta g que 10
secondes c'est mort c'est mort c'est bon
j'avais tout retirer à la vache en mai
mais non mais gros le mec il abuse pas
le attend le mec c'est quoi ce temps
faut 6 pouces et qu'elle arrive tout le
temps aux gueux langue mais qui passe à
jouer dans ce genre à se masturber ou
quoi déjà vu ça toi mec à 22h dans un
jantes 18 magazine
on dirait qu'il a invité ses potes à ce
monsieur éric lucas aux pires de trucs
ses limites c'est bon ça passe au il
reste une chaussette en quoi une
chaussette ça me fait perdre
non non non je refuse de nos boss qu'il
faut retenir de jeu finalement c'est
quoi c'est que cet enfant un gros
problème mental
on sait que sa mère arrive tout le temps
ambulants dans sa chambre et jamais
heureuse de le voir parce que son fils
passe ses journées à se masturber à ne
rien faire là pas à l'école et travaille
pas et ferrières du coup ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'on passe au jeu
suivant
non c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon
[Musique]
savez vous qu échouer ce quiz eastwood
est de retour avec de fuck mec a tancé
la barbichette de maxence la de florent
pagny rokita favorablement bureau quand
je fais un tournage on est sûr ricochet
qu'il est vous avoir simplement brésil
que je être la bouteille là où je
l'avais trop kiffé ou lettre qui fait
aussi terme un jeu c'est un peu le même
principe on a un certain nombre de
balles et il faut tuer un certain nombre
de personnes avec ses balles
dit comme ça c'est un peu bloqué il faut
utiliser le robot voilà comme ce qui
vient de se passer et je gérais geforce
seulement trois balles alors j'avais
cinq mâles à la base parce qu'on
m'appelle
j'en ai marre de dire ce pseudo nul
claque la coke est là on va en avoir
cinq facile là on va en avoir quatre
idées là on va en avoir
ben sol et il me reste capable et on
espère voir pardon j'avais mal fait mes
calculs je mets sur cinq personnes très
bien géré un pareil je m'en bats les
couilles des gamins et ouais gamma
hésitent à aucun moment je n'ai paniquer
wah wah doo ya autant duo actuel à ses
fins ce bordel qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont pas mis tout ce bleu sur mes
vidéos très bien huawei tout ce que j'ai
flingué je vais devoir d'exprimer les
mares de à bassam est clair voilà on
emballe plus elles sont morts ou pas du
coup où ils sont juste paraplégique
genre si je fais ça tu l'aimés cambrai
ou pas ouais hop hop et hop
et voilà et voilà je vais pas
d'arguments
ça dégage ouais les gens cool quoi il
faut un truc style et il se met du gel
hydroalcoolique sur les mains derrière
ok ok ok ça c'est très bien joué gamin
je pense qu'ici en faisant ça aux
troyens se leva les durs ça commence à
me prendre un peu la tête à ce que mon
chapeau était pas droit [ __ ] bah oui
[Applaudissements]
ok là soit revue food a annoncé voici le
voilà en anglais mais qu'ils abusent là
est là et pousse le et pousse le bouchon
quand même un peu je trouve un
accotement bien être des potasses quoi
faire c'est qu'on a compté jusqu'à 6 et
tout le monde va mourir ou non plus
wattrelos
c'est un corps il pas la terminale au
service
[Musique]
quoi mais georges le barbu lui fait quoi
le moment le mec et ce y est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes maintenant sur scribble
point you we c'est un joyau oui mais les
traites et cause d'avoir ce genre de
pictionary alors on va appeler jean
michel c'est parti et leur taille dans
une chambre et chacun de tous on va
choisir un mot comme gérald est en train
de faire actuellement ensuite du mal
dessinée nous on va devoir trouver ce
que c'est le problème c'est que les ide
et en anglais donc je pense que ça va
être la merde c'est jaune c'est le
soleil c'est ça oui et jean-michel on
était 3e à deviner moyens on est présent
ou pas dans le game trapdoor choisi un
mauvais titre up store c'est quoi ça
c'est une plante c'est un artichaut
artichauts salade laitue
mais c'est quoi chou fleur mais c'est en
anglais comme andy cole i-flow singes ou
la colle et flower colis colisée c'était
quoi le mot était colis flower haute
[Musique]
oh non j'ai mal orthographié j'ai
tellement une merde ok ça nous de
choisir entre pau midnight ou un lézard
un lézard
[Musique]
ils ont tous david ebbo lazare je suis
en train de faire des écailles peu merdé
vous comme ça je suis perdu j'ai vers
des banques critiquent pas médécin comme
ça de journée tu peux pas te permet de
me critiquer parce que moi je dessine
pas toute la journée suivant un peigne
un pin's un pagne voilà je voyais les
mecs ils dessinent pire que moi méme il
voit se croiser à hesmond les arts à
côté mon gars mais c'est la joue cool
fort qu une fourchette donc ça pour toi
cette fourchette ça et ben maxwell et
annoncé que depuis que tu es tout petit
tu manges en réalité avec un pet c'est
pas grave tu manges tu es [ __ ] de
pellicule mont gao qu'à nous qu'est ce
qu'on va faire deviner à ces petits cons
on va finir sur un truc magnifique un
microphone
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est un mec qui part dans un micro la
bon je vais les aider à les jeunes a été
retrouvé il part dans les migros ça que
j'ai décidé fait peu d'or aux jo on dit
il à quitter carrément c'est un mec qui
part dans un microphone mais [ __ ]
c'est un micro c'est un micro c'est un
micro trapdoor à trouver désolé si vous
êtes mauvais et bien voilà il avait déjà
pour cette petite compilation de jeux
n'étaient pas élevées si vous appelez
moi j'ai bien aimé aujourd'hui était
sympa allait bien sûr la description si
vous voulez y faire un tour
notamment ceux qui veulent premier opus
vous fera travailler votre anglais à la
tengo prochaine vidéo portez vous bien
surtout n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
ça